we talked a little bit about the
resistance equation that we got from dr
possa
and the equation looked a little bit
like this so
we had actually let me just replace this
we had
eight times eta which was the viscosity
of blood times the length of a vessel
divided by pi
times the radius of that vessel to the
fourth power and all this put together
gives us the resistance
in a vessel so thinking about just a
little bit more let's
let's uh assume for the moment that the
blood viscosity is not going to change
uh certainly won't change from moment to
moment but let's say that in general
blood viscosity is pretty constant now
given that if i want to
change the resistance then i have two
variables left right i've got the length
of my vessel and i've got the radius
so if i have a vessel like this and
let's say it's got a certain
radius and length and
let's say that radius is r and the
length is here
and i apply a number let's say the
number is uh 2
for the resistance
well i have two options for changing
that resistance if i want to increase
the resistance
i can do two things
so let's say i want to increase that
resistance
and you can look at the equation and
tell me what that answer would be
two things
and i'll actually draw it out so one
thing would be to keep the radius
basically the same
but make it much longer right because if
i make it longer
then since the l is now let's say twice
as long
and the r is the same now my resistance
is going to double so now we go two
times
and two times two is four so my
resistance is four
okay
option two
let's say i don't want to change the
length so i keep the length the same
instead i could actually maybe change
the radius and let's say i half the
radius and make it half of what it was
and i actually worked out the math in
the last one and it turned out that if
you half the radius
in the last video that is
then the resistance actually is 16 times
higher and you can see that because
the resistance equals
r to the fourth power here r is to the
fourth power
so because r is to the fourth power um
when you half it it goes up 16 fold and
so 16 times 2 is 32 so my resistance is
32.
so these are the two
strategies if you think of it that way
that a blood vessel can use to increase
resistance and of the two you can see
that one of them is definitely more
effective i mean i can see that because
it's raised to the fourth power this is
going to work much more effectively to
raise resistance
than changing the length and
additionally if you think of it kind of
from a practical standpoint keep in mind
that i have smooth muscles so it's
actually pretty easy to accomplish this
or at least possible to accomplish this
whereas
trying to actually change the length
which is option one is not feasible
right i mean it's much much more
complicated to actually
expect a vessel to simply double in its
length
because it wants to raise resistance so
for multiple reasons changing radius
again becomes the the name of the game
okay so let's complicate this a little
bit let's say instead of one vessel i've
got three vessels i've got let's say one
vessel here and there's this is uh let's
say five
and i've got let's say a longer vessel
here
and this one happens to have a
resistance of let's say 8 because it's
longer and let's do
the same radius for all these but
shorter now this one is 2.
and i want blood to flow through all
three of these
what is my total resistance and here
we're talking about
the
three vessels being in a series meaning
that you actually expect the blood to go
through all three of the vessels
or tubes
so if they're going to go through all
three tubes what you have to do is
simply add up
the total so
resistance
total so this is total resistance
and i just put a little t to remind me
that that means total
so total resistance
equals
the resistance of one part plus the
second part plus the third part and if
you had a fourth or fifth part you just
keep adding them up
so in this case you have
five
eight and two
so rt
becomes five plus eight plus two
and that equals fifteen so
total resistance would be fifteen
and actually i'm going to give you a
general rule so total resistance is
always
always
greater
than
any
component and you can see how this is
very intuitive right i mean how could
how could you possibly have a situation
where if you're just simply adding them
up you know because we don't expect any
negative resistance you know this
situation you're simply adding up all
these positive resistances of course the
total will be always greater than any
one component right seems intuitive but
i just wanted to spell that out
so now
let's take a scenario where
you have a human body a vessel in the
body and let's say you have
three parts to it
and these are equal parts so let's say
the resistance here is 2 2 and 2.
and you have obviously i want to
calculate as before my total
so my total will be two plus two plus
two which is six
and then an interesting thing happens so
you have let's say
i'll draw the same vessel again
really interesting thing happens
this is
the same blood vessel but now you have a
blood clot
and this blood clot is
floating through
the um
the blood vessels and it kind of makes
its way to this one this one that we're
working with
and it
goes and lodges right here
so right here
you have a lodged blood vessel
wow that's pretty big but it's right in
that middle third
of our
of our uh
vessel so we have now
a tiny little radius here right it's
about let's say half of what we had
before so this is the new radius
equals half of what the old radius was
and you know from the from the last
example that's going to increase the
resistance in that part by 16.
so the the resistance here stays at 2
here stays at 2.
but here in the middle it goes from 2
to
32 because it's 16 times greater
so you end up increasing the resistance
in the middle section by a lot
so let me just write that out for you
the 2 times 16 gets us to 32. so here
the resistance is
32.
and so if i want to calculate the total
resistance i'd get something like this
32 plus 2 plus 2 is 36.
so i actually went from 6 to 36
when this blood clot came and clogged up
part of that vessel
so just keep that in mind we'll talk
about that a little bit more but i just
want to
use this example
and also kind of cement the idea of
what you do with resistance in a series
let's contrast that to a different
situation and this is when you have
resistance in parallel
so instead of asking blood to either
kind of go through all of my vessels i
could also do something like this i
could say well let's say i have three
vessels again
and this time i'm going to change the
length and the radius
and let's say i have this one's really
big let's say
and
the uh
the resistance here let's say is 5 here
is
10
and here is six
right
so you've got three different
resistances and the blood now can choose
to go through any one of these paths it
doesn't have to go through all three
so how do i figure out now what the
total resistance is so what is the total
resistance
well the total resistance
this time is going to be 1 over
1
r1
plus 1 over
r2 plus 1 over r3
and you can go on and on just as before
but in this case we only have three so
let's just
put that there that there and that there
and i can figure this out pretty easily
so i can say 1
over
1
over 6 plus 1 over 1 over 10
plus
a fifth
and the common denominator there is
thirty
so i could say five thirtieths
this is three thirtieths and this would
be six
thirtieths
and adding that up together i get one
over
14
thirtieths
or
30 over 14
which is 2
and let's say 0.1
so 2.1 so the total resistance here is
2.1
putting all three of these together
pretty interesting and i want you to
realize that the resistance in total is
actually less than any component part so
unlike before where we said
that the
total resistance is greater than any
component here
an interesting feature
is that you have
total
is always
less
than any component
so pretty cool
set of rules that we can kind of go
forward with